hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast leveraging laboratory
information management systems to
provide standardization efficiency and
cost savings presented by Christine
Pasco PhD vice-president for sales and
marketing at accelerated technology
laboratories incorporated
I am Kaylee vaca bobberts and I will be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this even is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Pasco I will now turn the presentation
over to her thanks for that great
introduction Kaylee I'm excited to talk
to everyone today about leveraging limbs
to enhance standardisation efficiency
and cost savings before we start when we
talk a little bit about an agenda
why bother standardizing and we're also
going to talk about why this is
important especially in medicinal
cannabis market and also how a
laboratory information management system
can help along with laboratory
automation we're going to look at a
number of factors that are built into a
lens that help enhance data quality
speed of reporting and also analysis
we're going to look at tools built into
the system that help to enforce
terminology and standard operating
practices we're also going to
get the roll the Lim's plays in
facilitating regulatory compliance such
as iso 17025 as well as FDA rec
regulations such as CFR 21 part 11 one
of the major benefits of lenss and
laboratory automation is data security
and also note collection with limbs and
electronic laboratory notebooks and then
finally we're going to see what a major
role standardization plays in the entire
process when we think of standardization
we think of basically an entire process
and being able to have full traceability
from raw materials or manufacturing
aspirin or you're manufacturing a
cannabis product for medicinal
consumption if whether it's a candy or
if it's an oil or just anything you want
to make sure that the potency is
consistent so for example if someone
buys an aspirin and today it's maybe a
hundred fifty milligrams and then next
week it's only eighty milligrams people
will be not too happy that their
medicine isn't having the desired effect
so there are many things that are
checked throughout the cycle of raw
material to find final product
conversion and we'll talk about a few of
those so when we talk about full
traceability it's very important to be
able to have that in place in case
there's a problem with the finished
product if there's contamination with
the pesticide you want to be able to
trace that back to the original supplier
of that so that's one of the major
benefits that are in these types of
automated systems and also you know
there's a lot of regulations that have
come just in the last few years in terms
of the global food safety initiative as
well as has up we're also going to talk
about Bower coating for both 1d and 2d
as well as RFID and then taking a look
at how the testing can be monitored at
various stages through the product
development and then also rapidly
communicating those results of testing
that's found to those people that
require that information one of the
things that we're
look at is a lymph has so many functions
and features from the initial sample
that arrives in the laboratory to the
final result so from sample tracking to
inventory control in terms of all the
chemicals and reagents that are used in
a laboratory making sure you've recorded
their lot numbers their expiration dates
some clients also record the cost so
that when they need to reorder they know
exactly how much money they spent and
also what vendor has the best quality of
product because they can also link
testing data of their reagents and
supplies then there's being able to
enter data some data is entered manually
but for most of our clients the data is
entered via instrument integration
instrument upload and then reporting
automated reporting is also a huge
time-saver versus manually created
reports QA QC for quality assurance and
quality control these are control charts
interfacing instrument is a huge aspect
of standardization because you know
you've eliminated transcription errors
or errors from cutting and pasting and
then also chemical inventory being able
to manage and monitor the supplies in
the laboratory Resource Management
refers to managing employees training
certificates when they expire courses
taken all of the documentation that's
associated with an employee's expertise
and then there's crm customer
relationship management and this module
deals with an aspect that is really
related to ISO in terms of customer
satisfaction so when there's a problem
with the data that's generated by the
laboratory this feature allows the
laboratory staff to basically manage and
maintain the issues that are reported to
the laboratory whether it's a laboratory
report was missing a page or the result
was different from the result sent to
another laboratory for testing and then
there'll be a summary and a QA and then
also a free lens guy for anyone that's
interested again when we look at
production through analysis there are
many steps involved from the growing and
also they're doing any type of genetic
testing to the Harv
thing to the converting into finished
product now some of the aspects that are
very important in standardization
include repeatability so when you have a
process you want to make sure that you
can do that process flawlessly over and
over again and then also consistency of
product we talked about having the
potency consistent this is very
important in medicinal marijuana as well
this should be treated as any other
pharmaceutical this will promote very
strong customer confidence and the
finished product for those of you that
have a favorite coffee store you know
when you go to that coffee shop you want
the same taste and flavor over and over
you don't want to be surprised every
time with a different formulation of
coffee so standardization is also good
for customer satisfaction in building
market share and brand modernization
leveraging the latest technology to
basically become more efficient in your
operations interoperable
interoperability this refers to making
sure that everyone's trained in the same
manner so that if people need to switch
positions if someone's out sick they are
familiar with running that method and
they can just step in and you'll get the
same result as if the other person that
was out sick was there and there's also
manufacturing benefit and this was
actually first noted by Henry Ford where
people did the same thing over and over
and they were very consistent in their
output and it's also true with service
customer services like they have
consistency in your final product
there's also process standardization for
organizations and these allow for the
early detection of risk if there's a
problem in the product if a products out
of spec before more work is put into it
you can identify the cause of the issue
and remediated in terms of improving
external relations with customers and
suppliers one of the things that limbs
often have our web portals so that
clients can actually go and look up
their results 24/7 this cuts down time
into
calling the laboratory this also ensures
that the results are posted as soon as
they're available and because there's a
review process in the lens you know that
the results are accurate also it
increases organizational flexibility in
terms of cross-training employees are
happier on the job because they're given
the best tools to do their work and they
don't have to spend time cutting and
pasting results from an instrument onto
an Excel report or a word report and
also it increases organizational data
sharing and it's in a secure database
let's see so many laboratories currently
use outdated limbs or they have paper
and Excel notebooks or they've got
systems that have kind of been cobbled
together with a bunch of homebrew
systems and they're really leaving money
on the table because they're not being
as efficient and productive as they
could we hear many reasons why people
you know move to a newer system their
business needs change and the software
that they purchased five maybe ten years
ago is out you've outgrown it so when
you look at new modern systems some of
the features that you'll see include
very clean user interface the ability to
drag and drop instrument integration is
huge
being able to directly interface the
instruments with the limbs so that in
for some clients their instruments are
modern and they can actually create a
work list in the lens of all the samples
that they're going to run send that to
the instrument the instrument runs all
the samples and then sends back the
results to the limbs without any human
interaction and the nice thing is again
there's no opportunity for transcription
errors the entire fraud process is much
faster and it also results in time and
cost savings another area we talked
about earlier was corrective and
preventative actions so this is very
important in AI so if there's a problem
in the laboratory you can track it you
can track who reported it what actions
were taken to remediated how long it was
open the severity of the issue and who
closed it the nice thing is you have a
record of everything that was done on
that action
another powerful function of a lens is
the ability to do scheduling so if you
have tests that need to be run if you
need to do shelf-life studies those can
also be scheduled if you're talking
about a food product that may be now a
medicinal product so scheduling is very
important there's many things that
computers are very good at and humans
not so much and scheduling is one of
those another aspect is being able to
keep track of all of your instrument
instrumentation in the laboratory in
terms of when it was less calibrated
when it needs to be calibrated being
able to link the manual the electronic
manual to the system so again you have
one secure database that has everything
linked to it in terms of all the
operations of the laboratory rather than
having to run two paper notebooks or
Excel sheets or other systems that were
created internally then also we have the
ability to allow clients to change the
custom captions to terminology that
they're familiar with the advantage of
that this is that it facilitates a rapid
deployment and rapid adoption of new
technology and then also being able to
have a workflow designer allows
laboratories to change the way the
software works to meet their business
rules so with older systems that lack
this function as the clients business
changes or if they move into a new
business they really need to either
customize heavily their software or buy
new software with a workflow designer
you can just change the way that the
software functions in order to leverage
that technology another very powerful
tool is the electronic laboratory
notebook this allows laboratories to go
totally paperless there's many things
that can easily be managed in the limbs
and typically this is called structured
data this is data that's gathered for
example if you're doing a pesticide test
or a microbiology test you're doing the
same test over and over and over
eeehh lens or electronic laboratory
notebooks are good for unstructured data
so if you're doing some R&D or if you
want to test the new compound in
you're only going to do a few tests it's
not really data that a Lim's was
designed to manage but it's perfect for
an electronic lab notebook so you can
basically keep track of experiments that
you've done if there's any inventions if
there's any new compounds in there ideal
for managing this data they also manage
some structure data and they can also
interface with instrumentation in the
laboratory such as balances and pH
meters if we look at the total end
solution because there's so many
different aspects to it you can look at
being able to automatically print
reports being able to access the
software from anywhere with a tablet or
a laptop being able to generate labels I
still see some laboratories where they
manually print labels and I always tell
them that you know when you have a
mistake if someone's dyslexic like I am
and you invert the numbers that mistake
cost you money but if the lens is
already generating the number it really
makes sense to just have the label
printer print that number out there's
also dashboards where you can basically
take a look at the laboratory operations
visually it's very powerful being able
to schedule samples looking at
instrument integration looking at
external storage so that you can store
years and years worth of data being able
to have a web portal that's behind the
firewall where clients can access their
results 24/7 is also very important and
then also having a tool if you're doing
any type of field monitoring or work in
the plant where you can actually enter
results in it captures the GIS
coordinates and then sends that back to
the lens database next we're going to
take a look at some examples of
dashboards if you want to take a look at
the number of samples processed by the
laboratory who the largest client is the
workload capacity you can look at
freezers and refrigerators and
incubators if there's anywhere the
temperature is going below a critical
limit you can have it set up to
automatically send an email or call your
cell phone so there's a lot of tape
capability in these days
boards and each user may have different
things that are important to them so you
can also leverage user specific
dashboards everyone doesn't need to have
the same dashboard as we said before
positive ideas is extremely important it
mitigates errors to make sure that the
numbers that are scanned are accurate
much more accurate than hand entry and
much faster we've talked about one
dimensional bar coding for positive idea
of samples as well as two-dimensional
bar coding you can see in the second
example there's a lot more information
and then there's also RFID radio
frequency which is also becoming very
popular and the nice thing is with all
of these you can actually integrate this
technology with a lot of the
instrumentation to accelerate the
analysis even more so if you have an
analyzer that supports barcodes you can
have all the samples labelled and lined
up in that analyzer and it can read the
barcode generate the result and push it
back to the limbs without any human
intervention too often in the laboratory
we're drowning in data so one of the
major forces is to eliminate as much
paper as possible and with limbs you
have the ability to do that a lot of the
data comes off instruments and if you
don't have to look at printouts and
retype them into lens or push them to
excel and cut and paste them back into
lens you just have the ability to upload
them electronically it's much more
efficient and then also being able to
access that barcodes from anywhere in
the laboratory from sample a sessioning
or log in to final sample disposal you
can create a report of what's ready to
be disposed you can also automatically
generate a certificate of analysis
report as well as invoice reports and
you can also send them to the web portal
so that clients can download those
reports 24/7 and again all this is
reducing the carbon footprint making
sure that a lot lot less papers used we
talked a little previously about
instrument integration we're going to
talk a little bit more now and just
exactly how it works I often have people
ask me while I have an instrument
it's really really old can you still
interface it and the answer is as long
as there's an output file whether it's a
CSV comma separated value and Excel dot
XLS a text XML file new modern
applications are now leveraging Web
Services or you can also talk database
to database but as long as that
instrument has an electronic output file
it can be interfaced and lens
integration is a huge part of any
project that we do today just because
it's one of those places where clients
really get a rapid return on investment
I think we've interfaced over 550
different instruments and the list keeps
growing every day and the beauty of this
is it really makes sure that you have
the highest data quality it eliminates
the possibility of transcription errors
it's much much more accurate and it's
much quicker and in today's world
everyone seems to want everything
yesterday so that is definitely an
advantage the other aspect of lens that
is very nice is the ability to actually
look at the data that you're generating
and understand what it means so you have
the ability to view trends and create
control charts within limbs but many
systems also allow you to integrate with
statistical software so that you can
take a deeper dive into your data one of
the software's that we've integrated
with is JMP by SAS and they actually
have a number of different software
packages for different industries based
on on their needs which are really nice
next we're going to talk about customer
relationship management being able to
give clients the information that
they're looking for in real time and one
way that we can do this is through a web
portal from the lens so as lens manages
samples that are logged in sample
tracking data entry a sample scheduling
QA QC final reporting they show up in
the web portal in real time so once
they've been reviewed and approved in
the lens almost in real time customers
that are on a web portal that secure
can actually see the outcome of that
testing so some testing may already be
completed while other testing might
still be in progress but rather than
calling the laboratory and saying you
know you have my results is my tests
done they are empowered to go to the web
portal and see the results on their own
and if reports are available they can
download them 24/7 and the nice thing is
for the laboratory they have the ability
to see who's logging in who's
downloading reports and many of our
clients also have placed the invoice up
on the web portal so not only can they
download their final analysis report but
then they can also download the final
invoice one of the beauties of the web
portal again is it's available 24/7 but
the other thing is it's a hundred
percent automated from the laboratory
standpoint so once the testing has been
completed it's automatically pushing
this information to the portal there's
no human involved other than the IT
making sure that the server is running
and there's also a much higher level of
customer satisfaction because today's
consumers expect to get their data
electronically and on-demand one of the
biggest benefits is the cost savings
clients laboratories don't need to have
full time client service managers
wasting their time on stuffing envelopes
with final result reports they don't
have to take calls from customers of
past reports that were lost that need to
be resent they don't need to call them
checking the status they have the
ability to check the status themselves
and the fact that there's locked PDFs
that they can print they can print them
out as many times as they want so if
they lose them they can go back to the
state of warehouse and pull the report
they need and reprint it there's also
the ability to do field collection so if
there's large greenhouses and data needs
to be collected this information be can
be collected directly to a tablet the
beauty there is that you don't have
someone filling out a paper form
bringing it back into the laboratory
saying we've had a one or seven because
that data is automatically upload
is once it's entered into the tablet or
the the rugged laptop or the phone
there's a 95 percent reduction in paper
100 percent reduction in the paper
storage cost because all of these
clients that are doing any type of
environmental monitoring that falls into
the EPA they need to hang on to that
paper restore that paper for 10 years
and a 48 percent reduction in cost so
it's a very very smart move for
laboratories that are collecting field
data one of the other areas that people
are investing heavily in is moving their
software solutions to the cloud what
they found is it's very flexible pricing
it's a low cost of entry because they
don't have to manage and maintain the
servers the security that's required the
daily backups and also it's the
deployment is much faster they've really
offshoring their IT a lot of the small
laboratories don't have the funding to
hire a full-time IT administrator
especially when they're starting out and
having software hosted in the cloud is
an ideal alternative standardization
it's all about time savings quality
efficiency and being able to have full
trace pack regulatory compliance is also
very very important but when you
standardize your testing your
terminology it just makes the entire
organization more efficient and more
effective some of the benefits of
automation include having an electronic
chain of custody being able to be in
compliant with many of the regulatory
requirements security is also becoming
more and more important today and then
also being able to keep all of your
instrument calibrations your staff
certifications in one location and
within our system if someone hasn't
completed their training it won't allow
them to put results into the system for
the test they have not been certified on
in the same with instrument if an
instruments out the calibration it won't
let the end user utilize that instrument
for any testing it will tell them
calibrate the instrument or find another
instrument that's within calibration so
things like this that are built into the
zoo
to really enforce quality and compliance
with regulatory requirements we already
talked about the importance of
instrument interfaces being able to
manage inventory and then also being
able to do advanced analytics and
trending in statistics the major
advantage of automation really is
enhanced data quality being able to have
standardization across your organization
whether it's within the United States or
globally and then also cost savings it's
much more cost effective because you're
maximizing your resources by eliminating
mundane tasks that are better left to
computers and not people if we look at
some of the savings of automation 60%
resource savings with result point
client portal 48 percent savings and
these are from different clients and
savings vary by client based on what
their operational procedures are some
people have more room for savings than
others some are very efficient already
and they may see less than others that
are coming from a manual system so 48
percent improvement in lab processing
capabilities 99.9% system availability
for software in the cloud 55 percent
reduction in sample lifecycle processing
time and these are significant savings
on 93 percent reduction in time to
identify out of specification products
so the sooner that you can identify a
problem the sooner you'll be able to
mediate it
so in summary purchasing the right limbs
is very critical for the cannabis
testing laboratory standardization
really does enforce quality and one of
the things that ISO does is it basically
ensures that laboratories have a quality
management system in place so one of the
things that we hear a lot from our
clients is that they want to purchase
software and services from an ISO
certified firm so that they don't have
to do an internal audit on their own
because they know that that's already
been done by another organization making
sure you have the right tool for your
staff is very critical because
laboratories have very highly
brain scientist that our chemist and
microbiologist and they really need the
right tools to do their job if they're
spending time with a calculator checking
formulations by hand they really need to
automate that because one if they're
doing as a calculator each time they do
it they're doing it manually if the
calculation is placed into the lens it's
validated and it's locked it only has to
be done one time and then you know that
from there on forward the lens is going
to be doing it correctly so taking those
mundane tasks away from the end-users
and pushing them to computers really
does make sense the lens also
accelerates in enhances communication
across the organization I know when I
worked in the laboratory and if I was
looking for a sample I was always very
frustrated because the limbs we had was
very cumbersome and I'd have to walk to
the different departments like do you
have the sample Hank or you have the
sample and it was very frustrating to
get information so being able to look
the information up in a computer is just
much more efficient also the limbs and
laboratory automation tools such as
barcoding instrument integration
electronic lab notebooks all have a very
very fast return on investment they're
just things that make sense and also one
of the side benefits is helping
laboratories to meet regulatory
compliance goals as well as for cannabis
and other compounds that are similar
having a very strong internal chain of
custody and audit trail so basically
managing where the compounds are within
the laboratory or the raw materials
based on what you're working with so if
it was in the refrigerator if it was on
the bench top making sure that you're
tracking and you can do that with
barcoding you can scan it in and scan it
out who had it how much did they have
how much did they use how much is left
all of that information is very
important to track
I know we've covered a lot of
information I hope you've learned
something new today and it's going to
thank you for your time and also let you
know if you're interested in the Lim's
guide we'll be happy to send that to you
just reach out and thank you very much
thank you dr. Pascoe for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
well answer as many questions as we have
time for let's get started our first
question is what is the time to set up a
limp system in a small five to ten
person laboratory well it really depends
on the number of instruments the
laboratory has the number of
customizations if they're currently
using a system that they may need
historical data migration from and if
they have a dedicated project manager
but if they have maybe five instruments
or fewer it could probably be done in
three to four months if they have a
full-time project manager to kind of
take the lead on the project in
laboratories that are new are usually
much faster than laboratories that have
current processes in place that need to
be replaced our next question is can
instruments still be interfaced with the
cloud-based lens yes definitely if
laboratory goes to software as a service
in the cloud model the instrument
integration just occurs a little bit
differently where there's typically a
port in the firewall to allow the data
to be uploaded from the instruments and
we have time for one more question and
this one says what are the benefits of
using an electronic lab notebook if you
have a Lim's the electronic lab notebook
really complements the limbs and that it
captures all the unstructured data that
a limbs typically isn't the best at
managing and maintaining and it really
helps the laboratory to go paperless and
reduce their carbon footprint wonderful
I would like to once again thank dr.
Pascoe for her presentation I would also
like to thank lab rates for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for an on-demand viewing through jun 29
you will receive an email from Roberts
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us
don't be see you again soon goodbye bye